the technique of debate is a really
interesting and useful technique I make
sure to arbitrarily assign students the
side that they'll be taking in the
debate because it's pretty easy to
debate something that you feel
passionate about it's not so easy to
debate something that you don't feel
passionate about or where you feel the
other side is correct in terms of
learning it really is a I think it's a
great exercise because it forces people
to at least superficially understand the
stated arguments for the side they're
taking and then find a way to at least
be semi convincing about those arguments
and then I give them a period of time to
prepare to sort of prepare their
arguments about how they're going to
defend their positions and and then I
have them voice voice their arguments
for the particular side that they've
been assigned
so in crafting the arguments Pro if
you're a con you really have to start to
understand what goes behind those
arguments a little bit better and so
that's where the learning takes place I
think the other thing is that the
students get a little bit competitive so
they want to construct a good argument
they want to sound convincing and so
that extra little bit means that they
really do put in the effort to construct
a good argument and to make it
believable if I were making
recommendations to someone who had never
used a debate before I would say that
you should first of all don't pick
anything that's really emotional to
start out with so people can fiat have a
pretty strong opinion about it but it's
not something that's really deep so I
would stay away from something too too
touchy the other thing is there should
be it should be something where it's
really not a slam dunk one way or the
other so you want to make sure that the
the the topic that you choose really
does have two reasonable positions you
don't want to give one team just a
terrible thing to have to argue the
other thing you want to make sure is
that you give students enough time to
craft their arguments and to to debate
to debate the points so if you cut the
debate short after three minutes it's
just not going to help so you have to
set aside a pretty good chunk of time